[Musique]
dark.force c'est l'un des quarante films
danois projeté à regarde ailleurs
ici au lycée rotrou de dreux on compte
la plus importante section cinéma de la
région 150 élèves férus du septième art
elsa elle a eu un coup de coeur pour
l'incontournable l'arbitraire il aime
beaucoup violente et le public le lui
faire voir absolument tout il ne veut
rien lui cacher et c'est pour ça que je
trouve ça très intéressant donc moi oui
c'est vrai que au niveau du cinéma
danois le réalisateur pour lequel j'ai
vraiment gros coup de coeur c'est la
rentrée
melancholia millénium drive borgen le
cinéma danois produits films et séries
qui rencontre un immense succès à
travers le monde
ce peuple cultive à la fois un art de
vivre une certaine proximité avec les
arts et puis en même temps une certaine
rigueur parce que ce sont des gens qui
sont toujours des résilient qui sont
voire même des résistants à certains
moments et je pense que la combinaison
de cela chez leurs plus grands auteurs
fait que bargny il ya une vraie
dynamique créative avec toujours un
travail à la fois sur le fond et sur la
forme
le festival regards d'ailleurs ce sont
encore des rencontres avec des
réalisateurs celui de royal affaires
nikolaj arcel aussi scénariste de
millénium est attendu le 11 avril une
tête d'affiche attractive pour le
festival ou dix mille personnes se sont
pressées l'an dernier
[Musique]
et moi on poursuit notre tour du monde
en compagnie du groupe lo'jo il se
produit ce samedi soir à vendôme
les globe trotters angevins venus du
punk du jazz et du rock puisent leur
inspiration dans les musiques du monde
swing africain enfants font leurs
concerts c'est la promesse d'un
melting-pot musical dans son black blanc
beur pour lequel le groupe a reçu le
prix prestigieux songlines howard genre
2014 à landreau d'orgueil trempé
[Musique]
pour les tout-petits dimanche 1er avril
il y à des chasses aux oeufs organisée
dans de nombreux châteaux de la région
pâques c'est aussi comme tous les ans
l'occasion pour le secours populaire de
faire appel à la solidarité à tour à
bois à la châtre à issoudun dans l'indre
dans le noir et les enfants pourront
acheter un permis de chasse et des oeufs
pour un prix très modique et l'argent
récolté servira à financer des projets
solidaires à l'étranger on prend
maintenant la direction de la jamaïque
via le festival m'a cité va de belleu
tour dimanche après midi l'île aucard va
retentir de sand systems produit par des
vétérans de la scène française avec du
raggamuffin à gogo les soirées
performance est à partir du 3 avril au
théâtre d'orléans une huitième édition
qui propose un festival à la création
avec des séances d'une heure maxi qui
entremêle théâtre danse et musique comme
ici la performance des rois de la piste
l'un des tout premiers spectacles
expérimentaux à voir dès mercredi
prochain
bon week-end à tous
[Musique]